you will kick yourself in the ass
they're not taking advantages hi people
tell me not in the last year or two but
five years ago that were still around
from the big oil collapse that I
witnessed then we thought you were crazy
how did you how did you maintain your
resolve how did you keep your nerve just
keep running into the gunfire and
borrowing money now if oil had stayed at
five six dollars a barrel what I would
have been with a transcended bankruptcy
because there was virtually no way in
humanly possible that I could have ever
ever ever paid back all that money the
every soldier once said to not be alone
in the foxhole and that's why a lot of
guys turn to religion
this isn't changed my attitude about you
know familiarity breeds contempt
poorness rubs off and this is a time for
you not to be a pleaser this is a time
for you to get ruthless this is a time
for you to get selfish to provide your
family you and your family with the
riches I believe you deserve now if you
don't and I'm wrong and Corona last
twice as long as I think and you haven't
taken advantage of this opportunity
you're going to be big-time
you're gonna go down the toilet with
everybody else go out there run towards
the gunfire and kill him did I have
broken out of so many of my normal
routines which is interesting because
I'll caveat this and I'll tell you what
how I'm breaking out
I think routines is probably one of the
things people need to hold on to and I
think that there's there's a big risk
for people that just sort of get in a
weird place
if you don't force yourself to get up
and be productive and do that but
because I am so good at routines and
habits and I'm so regimented and I don't
need like to be pushed or encouraged
like I'm very disciplined in that way
because of that I'm creating new habits
and things around something that's more
playful that's more fun because I wanted
to it would be all too easy to look back
on this time and say that was a time
this this is not not good this is really
gnarly and so I thought I need to go out
of my way to make this a special time
something that I would look back on and
be like yo this is really fun and so
normally I work from the time I wake up
till the time I go to bed I'm either
working or working out but I've actually
introduced play time and so now I'm
working till about 7:00 7:30 and then
for the last hour and a half to two
hours it's me my wife and my sister
playing watching something fun playing
video games whatever are you doing
anything like that yeah yeah I think you
know like we know that the front line
work is the doctors the nurses the you
know I've seen you post about this too
and everyone who's like going out there
so that we can all be at home and be
safe like I think everyone is at home
it's a good opportunity for us to make
the most of that use time wisely because
there's a lot of people who still have
to go to work so I think first of all if
you don't have to go to work or you have
to work from home that's in itself a
good opportunity to engage and for me
it's been very much similar to what
you're saying so I've kept my morning
routine pretty much the same and if
anything I'm exercising more cuz I have
more time to exercise so I can get to
workouts in a day when I usually only do
one so that's been quite refreshing and
the evenings are exactly that so right
now it's me and my wife and
one of her best friends who's also my
friend staying with us and we've been
like you know we've been having movie
nights a couple of nights a week we've
been having a book club night a couple
of nights a week we're reading different
books and discussing and then we've been
having game nights twice a week too and
it's like you know it's I think people
don't need to think that because of
social distancing they can't have a
social life
and by creating a virtual social life
you still feel connected and you get to
laugh and play and and joke around and
do all the rest of it I mean you know
I've been saying this I've been getting
into the PlayStation time which I
haven't played for like I haven't played
PlayStation properly for like seven
years that being amazing I really got
into it my collection games my game
collection strong right now and I'm glad
that we're talking about this because
I'm guessing everyone who is gonna show
up on this chat doesn't think me and
you're gonna be sitting here talking
about games but but I'm hoping that ever
lose listening the reason why we're
doing this is because I just want you to
know that there is a need to do that as
well but not in replacement of right
it's not replacing the routine it's not
replacing the work ethic it's because of
this special scenario that we're in
right now that we're allowing ourselves
I'm catching up on this seven years that
I haven't played FIFA in in like the
last three weeks but I'm also at the
same time using my energy to work on
myself meditate longer workout more get
all of that in as well so just to adjust
a clarifying in case anyone was
wondering if me and Tom have got ruined
in most places in the progressive world
you own your time you get to decide what
to do for the next hour you can sell
your time to a loss or a client and then
the client and the boss controls your
time what else do you own well one of
the challenges that we have as we become
adults in the world and even at 50 or 60
years old become adults in the world is
making the choice to not sell our time
so cheap and making the choice don't
something bigger than what we're gonna
do today and we're living in this crazy
upside-down world we're in the middle of
a slog the economy is freezing up some
people are
by health some people are challenged by
having to deal with their family all of
it is a great excuse to not own anything
to just wait for somebody to show up
with a relief check or a client or job
but I want to argue today that this is
the perfect time to own something to
build something bigger than yourself and
what it means to be a bootstrapper is
not that you need a fancy venture
capitalist to write you a 5 million
dollar check so you can go public for a
billion dollars nor does it mean that
you need to go to the bank and
personally guarantee some fancy loan by
impressing some fancy banker now what it
means to be a bootstrapper is that you
find a problem that you find people who
are disconnected who need to be
connected that you find goods and
services in one place that need to be
somewhere else that you build an asset
and you pay for it because your
customers are so happy that you are in
the world doing the work you're doing
that they eagerly encourage you by
showing up with orders by showing up
with contribution that that cycle
bootstrapping
which is technically impossible lifting
yourself up by the bootstraps is not
only possible for an entrepreneur it is
the most common most productive way
forward
and so what bootstrapping is is thinking
very hard not about what your dream is
for how you want to spend your day is
some sort of freelancer who doesn't have
a boss but what does the audience you
seek to serve need who does who do they
need connection to how do we put
together the pleat the pieces so that we
have created value and made the world
better and there are healthcare workers
out on the front lines who are suffering
right now on our behalf to make things
better and if you can do that my heart
goes out to thank you but for the rest
of us there's the opportunity to build
an entity a project one where the people
we are serving would miss us if we are
gone your morning routine makes the
difference between going through a day
of misery and fear and apathy or be
productive and serving and using this
time to lift your life I mean
in the 5 a.m. club there's that the
20-20-20 formula that explains exactly
what to do between 5:00 and 6:00 to
battle proof your mindset to purify your
hearts to strengthen your health set and
to elevate your soul set what I call the
four interior empires in the book but
for now I'll just simply say the way you
begin your day right now is going to
dramatically affect the way your day
unfolds so start it with some exercise
so you release BDNF dopamine which makes
you feel better
serotonin which makes you feel better
and you know reduces the cortisol the
fear hormone start your day with
exercise which will release
norepinephrine which will allow greater
focus in your mind so we'll BDNF now if
you're at home you can say oh I can't
get to the gym jumping jacks
skipping running on the spot push-ups
burpees you can do it in any room even
if you're in one room that'll release
BDNF which accelerates the brain and
focus so meditation exercise 3
journaling journaling will allow you to
process through do it early in the
morning because like that's the morning
routine when you journal you can release
your fear you can release the emotions
of loneliness or and put them on a page
which allows you to feel much more free
so you can focus and and I think those
are three specific tactics that allow
you to start your your day better final
thing I'd say is prayer prayer works
very well for me even 3 or 4 minutes to
lock you into your highest largest self
is powerful this message I've been
giving you guys for years about what to
do and how to grow your business it has
never been more true than it is right
now ok this is what works bad news don't
work ok bad news don't work what's going
to work right now for you is getting
through this
me and I promise you I can get you
through this economy if you're scared
right now you should be I'm scared
I'm worried every day every single day I
wake up worried how long is this gonna
last how deeps are gonna be okay my real
estate is in perfect shape but every
piece of real estate around me the
retail store the movie Center the
Aventura Mall right here they're saying
they're saying that as many as 40% of
the malls in America could fail maybe
more every failure in your community
puts you and your company at risk this
is what I'm scared about everyday not my
stuff failing I'm worried about
everything around me am I getting cut
off Johnny are you good okay
I'm worried about everything around me
failing okay what works right now is you
need a plan okay persistence is the way
through all these problems you have to
you have to show up and work number two
okay you got to make real contacts today
I was on the phone this morning real
contacts okay I was on the phone with my
friend Tim Grover to decid tenth man go
on Instagram in any given moment they
got everybody think they're doing
something getting likes and comments
viewers viewership on lines up great but
is that a real contact with your buyer
is it a real contact okay first thing
I'm doing each day is making a list of
people that I can make real contacts
with set up a real appointment with
actually talk about something and number
two number two make an offer in these
contacts you need to make an offer this
is what I've been telling people to do
for years nothing's change them with
that I'm just gonna do it ten times
bigger and more I'm gonna go wider and
deep and I'm gonna insist on it so many
of your making contacts right now every
day I'm getting emails during this Cove
in nineteen moment we wanted to reach
out and see if we could be of assistance
to you how can we help you what can we
do for you how can we be of assistance
how can we you service you make real
contacts and make an offer okay quit
just offering help there's got to be an
offer that you make where they get to
exchange with you something that you're
doing
for them and number three never before
in my lifetime I've always said this was
the Holy Grail now it's the Holy Grail
on steroids
you have to follow up today your cycles
are gonna be longer because of the
uncertainty when uncertainty goes down
when uncertainty goes down
okay so dude does your ability to close
the deal when then when certainty drops
with your customers your outbound
activity has to go up to offset the
amount of uncertainty in the market
place make real contacts make real
offers follow up those organization
persistence right now team work is going
to be key I got something bouncing up in
the middle of the screen Johnny I don't
know if you see it it's gonna be the key
to you getting through this there's
gonna be a long cycle folks I think you
need to think about I think you need to
think about what are we in
we're in May 2000 2020 look if this
thing is over in January of 2022 I think
you're gonna be lucky if you're out of
work right now you need to go get a job
today make real contacts with real
people hiring people okay well grant
nobody's hiring anybody oh yeah you need
to make contact with a real person with
a real person they can hire you they
might not be hiring or they not paying
if you're a good person and you can help
them you can drive revenue and you can
bring customers I guarantee you can get
a job right now every company in the
world wants customers every customer in
the world wants revenue if you want more
advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate the coronavirus situation check
out the video right there next to me I
hope you find it valuable continue to
believe and I'll see you there that in
order to get the checks that we're
needing